all right
bentley yes bentley uh where'd you grow
up where are you from original i'm from
italy
south central south central and tell me
about your family you had both your
parents
growing up yeah well um i had my mom
well i knew both my parents i didn't
grow up with them
like i grew up with my aunt your aunt
yeah yeah
where was mom and dad my mom she stayed
in she like she moved around a lot and
then my dad i don't know my dad was
he was just in the streets was your dad
ever in your life
no i only met him once when i was six
you met him once and you were six yeah
what about your mom
i know my mom she's still in my life
she's been around yeah she's still
around okay
and uh how far did you go to school um i
finished high school
i just um i didn't go to college what
kind of kid were you in high school
huh what kind of kid were you in high
school um
i said like in the middle like i'll do
what i was close to but i would ditch
too
like i wouldn't go to school all the
time
and then you went on your own at what
age 14 14.
yeah so you started yeah not coming home
at 14.
um i ended up getting put in the foster
system at 14. oh was that right
yeah so i was in placements so why did
you go to the foster system
if you were staying with your aunt
because i ran away from home oh i see
and then prostitution came into the
picture what age 14
14 yeah how'd that happen um i know it
would be like a quick way for me to get
money
you had to support yourself yeah
did you do that with a pimp or on your
own on my own really
yeah how was that how did you remember
your first time
yeah it was like it was weird right it's
got to be right
yeah can you tell me about that first
time
um i was in pomona um it was a mexican
guy he was in a white pickup truck
and he took me at um 150 for um for
everything
so i was like okay so then we ended up
going to park on the street
and like it was like awkward because i
didn't know who it was so it's like
i just didn't say anything the whole
time i just like was hoping to like
hurry up and be over
and were drugs ever part of the picture
for you um i just smoked weed
and still to this day that's that's all
you do yeah
and you find doing this kind of work is
is okay if you're not
i don't judge myself like the money's
good so it's like
i mean like i do it on my own so it's
like i'm not being forced to do it or
anything
you've never had a pimp no i find it
like there's no point
so how much money will you make a night
around
800 to a thousand really yeah and what
do you do with all that money
i'll save it really yeah so you're
saving money
i mean i don't save all of it no you're
saving a big portion of that but
yeah you're not spending it on drugs or
attempts or whatever
yeah do you think you're one of the very
few that are
saving money doing this um it's probably
like a handful
yeah most of the girls i talk to yeah
say they're having a hard time
it's like it's hard at first but it's
like once you get like the hang of it
like you're um
like what you need and what you want
it's a big difference so it's like
once you narrow that down it's way
easier to save money yeah
and you're whole i'm 19. 19. yeah no
kids right
no you've been in love before
huh you've been in love before have i
been alone yeah you're 19. so i'm not
expecting the answer to be yes
um when i was younger
like when i was like 16 it's just a
crush
yeah so you're
you've lost touch with your family oh no
i still keep in contact with my mom and
stuff
and they know you're doing this yeah
they don't want me to but it's like
i gotta make a living yeah have you ever
had other jobs
huh have you ever thought about getting
another job or not really
no right because it's like why would i
go to making only like
27 bucks a day when i'm making this much
a day yeah it's hard to go back right
yeah just doing this kind of work ever
get to you does it ever
affect you emotionally um sometimes like
when it's like the days i don't really
make that much money
like you're gonna get to me but other
than that not really
and these guys you pick up are the guys
that pick you up do they
do you do you like them do you respect
them do you just tolerate them
i mean i just try to get the date done
over with it's just money
yeah yeah and do you think doing this
kind of work
and interacting with guys like this
might change the way you view men
yeah yeah i could see at night yeah
all i can tell you is not all guys are
like that um yeah a lot of the guys
they're high and they just want to
have some fun with a girl right you just
want to hang out yeah
are you pressured to do stuff you don't
want to do like drugs or without a
condom or anything like that
i don't know no everything's with a
condom and i don't do drugs
but you get asked huh you get asked yeah
but i don't do it
yeah it's good it's not enough money in
the world
like for my health
and what do you think opened your mind
to even doing this kind of work because
it's not
not a common job for a young girl i
don't know money and you had friends
that were doing it
no i was just i knew like like a lot of
girls like they made money like easily
it's hard to drive down fig without
seeing
what's going on so i was like i mean
like it's not that hard just to go
outside
and just stand outside yeah you probably
get a proposition whether you're just
going to grocery store or
yeah trying to make money there's tricks
everywhere
yes there are
what kind of things have you learned
from doing this um
i learned how to read people your
intuition's probably heightened right
yeah like i learned to go with my
stomach like my gut feeling
um i learned how to like approach
certain people like
know how to like work with them if that
makes sense yeah like like
the vibe i'll get off a person i know
how i have to go about it with them like
how to like deal with that type of
person
have you had bad things happen um
one time but not like the most like
baddest thing that ever happened was i
had to jump out of a car
it was pretty bad like that was the
worst thing but other than that like i
haven't really had anything happen
luckily
and where do you see your i mean you're
19 what do you think you'll be doing in
in five ten years i probably have a
bakery
so you're saving money and hoping to
yeah i like the bait
change careers yeah
it makes sense on paper i'm not sure
you know there might be some other price
you might pay down the road but maybe
not
what do you think most people don't
understand about girls that do this kind
of work
um it's not like what we do that make us
like
we're not bad people it's like we're
just trying to make a living so it's
like
people can judge us all we want but it's
it's not like it's not their life
they're living it's
our life so but is there something about
the culture down in south central that
makes this like a more attractive option
because like
there are other
parts of the country yeah i would say
most parts of the country that this is
not
acceptable no one does it yeah but if
you drive down figaro street right now
you're gonna see so many girls doing
this right
yeah i feel like that's what like makes
it like easier for most girls like
you see it yeah you grew up you're like
well they're out there like
what's the most that could happen yeah
when you see a girl wearing with her
with her ass hanging out of her shorts
middle of the day yeah a six-year-old
girl looks at that and like what's she
doing
and eventually you figure it out right
yeah when they get about older like 12
11.
do you get pressured by pimps too
sometimes but
i don't really pay them attention and
you can get away with that nobody's like
as long as i don't say anything to them
no but but like there are also other
hustlers that are like trying to control
the oh like knowing like they don't know
i have a like don't have a pimp
yeah i mean i made one that like so it's
like when they ask me like do i have a
pimp i'm like yeah and i'll just say his
name is banks or something oh is that
right
yeah you're smart your street smarts are
getting you through
yeah there's plenty of people out there
so it's like you don't know who exactly
i could be talking about
that's great you've been arrested yeah
yeah
um four times no i've been arrested
three times
how long day how are you from just a day
and then i'll be ordered out
the longest was overnight in arizona
like they kept me overnight and i had to
see the judge in the morning
so you're traveling for this too
sometimes yeah
and why would you travel just to i mean
it's different places like you get to
see the world
it's a way to see the world i guess yeah
interesting
does does doing this bring any shame for
you or anything like that or you just
you just see it as a
way to make a quick buck i don't feel
shameful about it i don't
know like it's my decision yeah
i mean at first when i first started
like yeah i felt shameful like
but then like i got tired i just like
felt like i shouldn't think about what
other people think about me
right but if you fall in love with if
you meet a guy that you fall in love
with and then he finds out you're doing
this i could
i mean i wouldn't like hide it from like
you should just accept me for who i am
if you can't then i'm not the one for
you would that would a relationship like
that
stop you from doing it probably not
i mean if i was in that type of
relationship i wouldn't be doing it no
more
right but i want to be in a relationship
right now
yeah you want to make money yeah
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your 19 years
don't trust everybody do not trust
everyone
a lot of snakes out there a lot
how does it feel like everyone you
interact with
the tricks the other girls the pimps the
hustlers on the street the cops even
maybe are up to no good or
they're i mean the girls like they're
pretty cool like i don't really have any
problems with nobody
no and the guys like the pimps i don't
really talk to anyone and then like
it'll be like you know little homeless
people walking up and down the street
like they're pretty cool they'll say hi
you know make sure you're okay like i'm
a nice person
so it's like i give off a nice vibe you
must be doing something right because
yeah you don't have the horror stories
and you seem to be getting by
fairly unscathed right yeah like i try
to go with my um like
my stomach feeling like before i get in
the car with someone if i don't feel
right i won't get enough
say no sometimes yeah i'll say no right
all right bentley well thank you so much
for talking with me thank you i wish you
the best of luck
very interesting angle on this you have
thank you you seem to be uh saving money
which is which is which is rare
yeah all right good luck with your
bakery thank you
thanks